وقال الكريم ان هناك الكثير من الاسلحه
الاسئله بشان مساله عدم الانتشار النووي
في ضوء خطط نقل الغواصات النوويه الى
استراليا من جهته اعلن وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سلبيه خلال افتتاح المؤتمر
التاسيسي للحركه الدوليه نحبه روسيا ان
العالم الانجلوس ساكسوني بانشائه تكتلات
على غرار اوكس ودفع البنيه التحتيه الى
اسيا يعد اعلانا جادا للمواجهه
العلم الانجلي بانشائه تكتلات على غرار
اوكوس وتعزيز البنيه التحتيه العسكريه
للنيتو في اسيا يكشف عن اعلان جاد عن
مواجهه لسنوات عده لانني لا اتخيل كيف
يمكن سحب الحضارات الاسيويه العظمى تحت
مظلتهم كما والد اسف تم سحب الاتحاد
الاوروبي لينفذوا بطاعه خطط واشنطن
وزملائها الانجلوس ساكسونيين نحن لا نحاول
ردع اي كان عن تحقيق مصالحه الشرعيه عندما
يصرحون بضروره اخضاع العالم باجمعه لحلف
شمال الاطلسي على سبيل المثال